the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers it's a whodunit and we're gonna
tell you who did it okay so one last
time
spoilers
[Music]
from the director who ruined your man
childhood comes a film about how if you
act like an entitled dick women and
minorities will take away everything you
ever loved no not that one the new one
and mute thread knives out get ready for
a brand new whodunit murder mystery but
since Roger never met an expectation he
couldn't subvert he'll tell you who done
it right off the bat plus where it got
did and how it get done then slowly
reveal who helped done it who done knew
about it and why it all got getting done
in the first place
it's more of a how done they get away
with it really whatever you gotta do
getting heated meet the thrombi z--
heirs to the world's most sumptuous
sweater collection and a mansion that
looks like an Applebee's themed escape
room their patriarch is Christopher
Plummer the best actor to ever get
typecast as the wealthy head of a
miserable rich family when his suicide
is ruled a murder everyone is a suspect
because he spent the night giving his
entire family reasons to kill him the
last money you will get from me dad are
you firing me Harlan was cleaning house
not a red dime or word of my work to a
single one of them you included me come
on man don't you know cutting off your
relatives is the number two cause of
death and rich people see right behind
ya mutiny taking the case is Benoit
Blanc a detective who could really use a
fidget spinner
[Music]
played by an actor who could really use
a dialect coach whoa okay we got
footprints
he's more southern than a confederate
flag soaked in deep-fried mint juleps
foghorn leghorn draw but don't
underestimate this simple country
detective because he's so good he
doesn't know who's paying him who hardly
I do not know does an interview keep
witnesses for days I think you have
something you want to tell me and that's
the main suspect almost died in his care
twice you'll need all the help he can
get from Marta Cabrera a nurse with a
rare form of bulimia just the thought of
lyin it makes me puke
a condition that any good detective
could use to crack the case in 30
seconds
but this half-cocked Sherlock can't even
smell the lies right in front of him
you're not much of a detective are you
you know I'll say for a film called
knives out this uh detective yo is about
a sharp as a bowling ball so if you love
a listers a-holes and Agatha Christie
ride along with the silly fun not really
a mystery where everyone's a red herring
and the most famous guy helped do it in
the end really the only question you
have is how one housekeeper kept an
entire mansion full of knickknacks
secret passages and hidden piles of
nurse pew clean yet more blood hose from
ruined Johnson hashtag remake knives out
with more puke cleanup scenes story
better called raw if you need to spew
spew into this that is America's talk
gonna take this house from the Oh frown
strode trash bridges Michael Caine
inherit arey 13 reasons why you're out
of the will Frank Oz the great and
powerful get out get out old Deuteronomy
hand Kevin Spacey
the last P i if Harlan wanted to kill
himself while clearing Marta have any
suspicions why didn't he do it in front
of anyone else in a house full of people
we wasted a real lawyers time defending
movie Joker's at
paid a real psychologist to analyze
Harley Quinn in our series fandom IRL
click here to see what happens when your
favorite heroes stop being polite and
start getting real wait am I allowed to
say that having fun isn't hard when
you've got a library card